Ryan needs the help of his local food
bank he says a mental health condition
means he can't work
but as the cost of living crisis gets
worse he says the money he gets isn't
enough to live on things are being quite
tricky for me recently due to being on
benefits I'm on Universal Credit
um which has made me realize that I'm
now having to choose which Bill I'm
going to pay or which Bill I'm not going
to pay to put food on my table Boris
Johnson had committed to raising
benefits in line with inflation but Liz
trust seems less sure and that's angered
those working on the front line of this
crisis I think it's really important
that benefits increase at the same rate
of inflation the people that we are
getting through this store here the
elderly the young people disabled people
they are suffering huge stress that
stress is manifesting itself into
illnesses some people are disabled they
literally have to make choices as to
whether they can put food on their table
or turn their Lighting on and to to
think that they can survive live on
anything less than an increase that
matches the rate of inflation really is
just it the government's out of touch
with the people who are suffering in
this country it's understood that
Downing Street is considering increasing
Universal Credit in line with average
earnings instead of inflation and that
would mean a real term cut for claimants
Tory MPS are worried about the message
this sends to voters at a time of
hardship for Millions what we don't need
is a disrupter what we need is a unifier
and I think probably that the new prime
minister has realized that over the last
few weeks and whereas I fully I am fully
on board with an agenda for growth we
also have to be very careful that we
don't throw and I said this so many
times before the baby out with the bath
water
senior Tories leapt to defend the Prime
Minister aware that the conservatives
are plummeting in the polls we'll always
be on the side of those households that
need the most help but until we have the
process complete at DWP no decision has
been made on the Universal Credit
um on the benefits operating
labor now surging ahead in the polls
have accused the government of placing
the burden on low-income families all in
the name of wider economic growth what
we've got is a reckless approach a spike
in borrowing costs and now the
government as we understand it are
talking about asking working mums and
dads disabled people poorer pensioners
to pay the price for that recklessness
the department for work and pensions
will start their annual review into
benefits later this month as part of
that they look at the rising cost of
living to figure out just how much
benefits might be lagging behind
this could be a critical turning point
in how the government is seen to be
helping those most in need is the cost
of living crisis deepens McMartin Sky
News